bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj ci siamo dati su
geometri dash quella unica
no non è razzismo era africano su
geometrie vabbè comunque ragazzi siamo
tornati su geometri dai freddi venti
ragazzi non vedevo l'ora perché ho
scoperto dopo secoli click si possono
cercare i livelli personali quindi se io
scrivo fa vj appaiono 14 miliardi di
livelli quindi se è bellissimo è
praticamente madonna se c'è 620 libero
kay avete fatto 620 livelli per me non
mi faccio tutti mi sa i propri di
ragazzine che possiamo cominciare spero
che siano tranquilli altrimenti p uccido
la vita partiamo con questo che mi
sembra ok mi sembra una merda no scherzo
scherzando è era foga del mondo così che
cazzo passion nuvole lo è chi è che ha
scoraggiato rosa non lo chiama ragazzi
già già su un partito che non ho capito
un cazzo
bene così è la madonna passo di sotto ad
un posare dirlo cazzo come cosa ci
dovrei avere le ali per falsa cosa si ho
capito che botta di culo
non so neanch'io come ho fatto ma va
bene così ok la lam e ovunque amico mio
ma sei un emo taci tu a 80 per cento e
remo supporto suo livello mi sembra che
l'unico
meglio così i ragazzi 6 masochista di
qom io non lo so va bene come siccome
come fa un essere umano a fare come
hanno fatto suo livello
voglio sapere il nome indirizzo via ste
nuvole di merda perché ci sono le nuvole
adesso mi spiegate da [ __ ] cioè ci
sono due strade credo di qua cosa era
con la merda ragazzi io sta parte ii non
lo sapevo che si potesse pasta roba
sinceramente ok
bene adesso che sono diventato sto
schifo avevano sì che curò va bene con
job tempo il 26 ce l'ho fatta ragazzi
durate anche poco la musica sta
continuando a caso
va bè ragazzi è stato tre minuti ma
pensavo peggio molto peggio il primo
livello è stato fatto da pac cube che
non ti ucciderò la vita però vedremo il
prossimo che sono più difficili sa
perché c'è la faccina triste
cos'è quella merda beh a bell ab è bella
a tutti i ragazzi perfetto giuseppe cosa
è successo nel mondo la bella bella un
cazzo cos'è successo
no seriamente cosa era cioè torna
indietro che cazzo ma serio sta roba mai
vista ma va bene bella una sega con
l'hiv aids
ok se già fatta
giova e vabbè ma che per chi mi hai
preso per un deficiente amico mio lo so
che ti piace quando mi fa incazzare però
il problema è che è che mi fa incazzare
no no no mortacci dura cosa simpatica
misto livello e che muoio come un
deficiente poi c'è scritto bella bella
un cazzo è una roba
no no no non è possibile ragazzi
chiunque chiunque abbia fatto sto
livello lo troverò il ucciderò prima
possedete mica sei ok non devo cliccare
si mondo voti che un cazzo bene bene una
sega però meglio praticamente ragazzi e
un certo provava a [ __ ] c'è stato un
momento in cui non ho capito più eco
perfetto saltare ok ok ok ok se no il
triangolo no no mortacci guardone bossi
è una cosa ok bene già fatta ho fatto a
caso cosa facciamo
cosa c'è scritto non voglio leggere
amico mio perché mi sento sicuro non sto
capendo un kart c'erano delle scritte ho
vinto a caso va bene avvenne così è
stato bello amico mio e stato veramente
bello molto tanto la musica continua a
caso va beh ok all amico mio ti metto un
po liscione in su come fate tutti al
lido vero andiamo col prof player questo
nome
originalissimo si prova ragazzi perché
mi sembra un po che cazzo estero o mio
dio sta roba quanto starle le note
musica perché ci sono delle note
musicali a caso queste frigo forse non
tanto cioè non riesco a far due metri ma
va ok gesù vi sembra normale amico no
dimmi se ti sembra normale ma come cazzo
a faccia di quello tenere premuto ne
sono non va si ok bene cos'è sta roba
cos'è i vostri livelli già quelli
normali non li ka cristo che al green
non li ka cristo già quelli normali non
li capisco questi figuri niente da fare
niente c'è verso che io odio questo
gioco dal profondo le quali forse che
mario non è abbastanza
ma non ci passo spesso la faccia che
dire bene euro
e bello complimenti ok ce la puoi fare
lo sbattere la testa
si ok no eh vabbè poi non ho veramente è
una cosa indecente se avete mai giocato
a una roba si è fatta calmi calmi
cosa dio cos'è oggi mi sto anche salvato
niente c'ero quando probabilmente non ci
riuscirò mai più nella vita ma
[ __ ] dai vai vai vai se c'è la
storia ragazzi charlie faccio studiando
il mondo in assoluto proprio guardali
che schifo bene allora si si si calmi
che non so capi un cazzo ok fa vj al
contrario bello bravo amico mi sono
lasciato distrarre dalla scritta fa dj
io ti uccido mi sono troppo gasato nel
fatto che c'era la scritta far niente ok
ok ok non mi distrae un bene adesso e
non è che perfetto tanto adesso la
scritta a metà perché non lo so
ragazzi è stato bellissimo però la mia
scritta e si è rotta alla fine ma va
bene veramente sono figli sti livelli
maiale alessandro potresti essere il
prossimo alessandro a morire sappilo
proprio questo perché incazzatissimo
però mio dio è un tantino veloce mi
sembra una roba infatti a ok c'erano
cosa della velocità che ti diminuisce
chiama store
sto robot diminuisce che figo o mio dio
vabbè ma cazzo si fa così schifo si o
mio dio
questo fatto non ce la farò meglio nella
vita non devo morire sono morte 30 per
cento ragazzi mi accontento del 30 per
cento
ok bene bene come ho fatto a morire
prima così no non sopporto questo morto
sono morto maraga veramente io non ci
posso credere
ok ok ok bene così bravo o no un pene
viceversa
cosa è successo ok sì sì sì che culo a
caso è vabbè dai è già qualcosa ok io
ragazzi non so come fa bastava stare
fermi ok perfetto bene mio dio cos'è sta
roba perché ci sono i marsi andava senso
vietato la navicella ma regala niente
soste cose come faccio a giocare se non
so cosa mi trasformi bene
bravo bravo tua mamma ok ragazzi non ho
capito ma ok ma una vice ma perché ci
sta navicella da schifo qualcuno per
favore mi spiega che cosa dovrei fare
sì sì sì bene ok va bene così non so
cosa ho fatto me ne frega un cazzo
[Musica]
sì un mio dio cosa a caso ragazzi sto
svenendo 95 95 io mi ammazzo
non ci posso che non arriverò mai più
nella vita a quel punto lo sapete vero
neanche capito come ho fatto a passare
quel coso con la navicella impossibile
sì non lo so non ho capito di nuovo ma
va bene ho davanti senza capire che il
caso sto facendo ma ok dei ragazzi dopo
questo livello da fare il monaco in
nepal che non si non esiste lo ok ok
vediamo se riesco a moria di nuovo
[Musica]
lo stavo facendo senza guardare lì che
mi fa incazzare ancora di più una roba
ragazzi adesso ci penso mi è venuto in
mente che avete scritto tipo role ma
tanto fa vi si vede che non giochi tu
dovete capirmi ma ci sono delle persone
che hanno disturbi a livello
neuropsicologi farmacologico quindi devo
fare così per forza per adesso riesco al
primo tentativo così che è più difficile
di prima ci riesco non si sa come ok
bene una bellissima io la adoro abbiate
pazienza ad ora un po meno a livello pro
va bene ok ok non ce la posso io so già
che non ce la farò ragazzi so già che mi
devo incazzare come un non so cosa
sì ma come si fa a questa parte sì sì a
caso e vabbè vabbè ho vinto per ragazzi
è stato bello e perfetto alessandro sei
la persona che preferisco si può vedere
dove abita alessandro informazione un
ragazzo è stato bellissimo io concludo
qui perché sono troppo bravo ce ne sono
620 ragazzi 620 ingresso per tutta
questa generosità nei miei confronti
quindi grazie ragazzi di cuore quindi
ragazzi vi ringrazio di cuore spero che
vi sia piaciuto spero che alessandro mi
contatti da qualche parte mi dica dove
abita è quindi ragazzi se il video mi è
piaciuto consentono sotto commento mi
piace anche a bersani facebook e comuni
lo trovate la descrizione senza vorresti
discreto l'incipit della ragazzi